in February 2014 I did a video on
pornography was my addiction I mean not
want until Farrah's topic I'm not joking
once hit on knowing who you are in
Christ is just to get closer to God why
can't black people have nice things
why because I know you want to be like
like me excuse me say what
it's almost like some white people are
allergic to black people being happy
also a very oh but thank you so much for
joining us and divided as we so often do
easiest place for us to start is how
would you describe yourself what is it
that you do and so I'm an influencer are
I do Beauty I do Chatty videos where I
talk about different issues affecting
black women in the UK and also taboo
issues as well what's your experience of
being a black woman in the UK at the
moment
I mean clearly racism is still here it
is still an issue but it's certainly not
we're not where we were you know 10 20
30 years ago
I mean racism whether it be now or 30
years ago shouldn't have been a thing
anyway but I think it is great I was
even thinking about this this morning
but we're able to have conversations
like this openly and not be scared of it
I think that's the first step
why do you think in this day and age
that you have as a black influencer I
had a different treatment to some of
your white colleagues I think I think
we've always been used to seeing one
type of beauty and especially if the
world of influencing is so consumed by
beauty and aesthetics and we've been
taught when we see magazines or when we
see TV adverts or the leading lady and
movies they're usually like white women
a lot of the time it was blonde women
with blue wires and I think we've kind
of moved on from that but a lot of the
time it was white women with very white
features very slim noses lighter skin
lighter eyes and I think when you're
used to seeing one thing as beautiful I
think it can be difficult to expand and
accept the you know plus-sized women and
dot a dark-skinned women and Asian women
can also be beautiful and accepted as
well there's a lot of brands out there
an appropriate urban culture black
basically black culture black slang and
black hairstyles like fashion they
appropriate that they steal it for their
own good and then they don't represent
us on social media they don't represent
us in campaign we never see them or
their Instagram pages that's webpages
their Facebook pages all the models are
why many of why people with mixed-race
children also ignore the racism that
affects the black community and I know
that when me and my brother traveled to
America for the first time my brother's
a slightly darker than I am he was given
bleaching cream by somebody and told
that he needed to get lighter and I
think you know it's a thing of access in
Nigeria the light that you are you can
you have access to better jobs and if
you look at movies for a very very long
time even in black movies the leading
lady was always light-skinned if you
look at the 1960s a lot of the Lena
thorn a lot of those women were like
what we're lighter skinned and it took a
long time for people like Lupita Nyong'o
and Danai gurira to be appreciated and
nothing that's why Black Panther was so
successful I mean you mentioned the film
black panther and clearly that had a
huge impact on all communities around
the world but particularly black unities
why was that because even - again -
white Scottish shines it seemed almost
with the African accents and the the
style of dresses at times to me it
looked a little bit cliched almost mmm I
think I think as a black person for me I
saw myself represented and I think it
could be cliched but when you have the
when you identify with that experience
you're able to see the nuance there are
so many different nuances of the film
especially when you saw a Michael
Jordan's character who was stuck in
America who seemed like he would he was
lost and that was speaking so much about
dice the dice Boren community so people
like myself who weren't necessarily born
in Africa but we still have ties to that
place and treated like we're African
even though we're born in the UK and
feeling that sense of loss of I'm not
white enough to be seen as British at
times but I'm also not African enough to
see to be seen as African and that was
an amazing nuance that I don't think was
cliche in the film and I think just that
that film brought out a lot of
conversations in the African
munity that was I think really important
sick of men many why women fetters
writer pet fetishizing black men's
bodies and then continue to objectify
them and when they see them dying on the
street on on the news in person on
Instagram on social media platforms they
either ignore it or they justify the
police hashtag blue lives matter and all
this nonsense but you want hashtag blue
lives matter than last week sis when I
saw you scrolling on kwame's Instagram
obviously politically at the moment with
a lot of discussion about Breck said a
lawsuit a discussion about mass
immigration and the rest of it that has
also been something of a national
conversation about racism I mean in your
view do you see Britain as to any extent
as a racist country would you describe
it in such terms I wouldn't say it's a
racist country I think when we look at
racism I think we need to step away from
seeing it as something that's overtly
vicious I think it can also be quite
subconscious and I think some of those
subconscious tendencies show up in
different ways I'll give you an example
of that thing I think just
microaggressions as I said before in the
workplace so I don't think it's over in
the sense of people want to be awful to
you I think it's just I'd be unlearning
that we need to do in in all communities
all over like in different countries and
I've seen this mentioned by my
subscribers who live in all sorts of
countries so it's not I don't think it's
something that's over it's definitely
subconscious a lot of your experiences
you've talked about through through the
YouTube channel and through videos
online and one caught plenty of people's
attention because of the subject matter
back in 2014 and that was your addiction
to pornography the beginning of this
story starts when I was about six or
seven and I was abused and it was I
don't even know how to
says yes about three nine years old I
started masturbating and quite often
when I would feel depressed or when
something bad was going on in the home
it would start again and be more
frequent and every time I did it I felt
like I just felt really dirty and I felt
like obviously being in a Christian High
Line I literally felt like God was
looking at me and I was going to hell
just tell us a little bit like that and
so for me I experienced pornography
addiction
due to the fact that I was molested at
five years old and that sexual abuse
went on for five to six years and that
sort of awoken it'll it'll work feelings
inside me I think that we're just very
premature so just needing sexual
gratification at a very very young age
almost before you're able to understand
those feelings and because I hadn't I
felt such shame and I never spoke to
anyone about them they kind of festered
inside me and what happened is that they
it just it went to the point where I was
seeking out that gratification and
that's when my porn addiction started
and that continued for about five to six
years until I became a born-again
Christian at 20 years old how bad did it
get because I'm sure you have rolled
your eyes sometimes that people who've
code that said that they're addicted to
their soul addicted to the night and
it's not they just like it yours was a
use was a proper addiction wasn't it I
think I think addictions are hard
because you do like it at first but it's
a it's a cycle I think for me it was a
it was also escapism so anytime I didn't
feel good or all those feelings of abuse
came to me I went out seeking the
addiction and at first it was really
really like I wasn't watching it for
that long but at its height when I was
about 20 years old I was watching it for
quite a few hours a day every day and I
don't even think it's just about
watching I think it's about thinking
when you're thinking about you may not
actually be watching it but when you're
thinking about it and how much time that
takes up in your mind and how that
changes your mind about you know sex and
how you see your body image especially
as a woman the bodies in porn on
weighs the most realistic so it's also
those effects as well that are part of
the addiction that there will be some
people as well watching this for whom
the revelation that you know there are
women who enjoy prolong it will be just
that a revelation I think yeah I think
that is the good one of the good things
about talking about this is that you
know women like sex I'm a virgin waiting
for merit marriage but as a human as
human beings you know we are create well
most of us are created to enjoy sex like
and I think there is that feeling that
women don't I think there's that feeling
that women aren't interested in sex or
they're not interested in being
pleasured and I think that's due to
sexism and I've got so many emails by so
many other women who said that
pornography addiction was a big problem
for them and that made me realize it
wasn't just me
and I think the more that we have
conversations about pornography
addiction that we have more
conversations about sex especially as
women I think that might open the gate
so that people realize that it's
something that women are interested in
too it's easier to keep my thoughts
pulled pure because I haven't had sex
however obviously I was addicted to porn
but one thing that really helped is I
actually have a blog on how I can't
conquered my pornography addiction and I
think that'll help people I think it
crosses over so it's great for people
who were addicted to porn but it's also
good for people who are struggling
within impure thoughts and and stuff
like that so read that or watch the
video I'll link them both below you
think being a virgin in today's society
turns guys off from a potential
relationship it turns the wrong guys off
how did finding God you see she's at you
became a boat you are born-again
Christian how did finding God leap to
the end of that addiction for me it was
just really seamless like I
I've spoken to other Christians that
they still struggle with porn even after
being Christians but for me it was just
I became a Christian in July of 2012 and
I just never touched porn again I was
very afraid that I would and I remember
just being in my bathroom just like in
the bar just crying and being like God I
really don't want to go back to this
because I
it had a such a hold over my life and it
just never happened again
and I didn't even want to make that
video in 2016 or so but I really felt
led to and I'm I'm glad I did so - what
what then did thank you
what made you meet that make that video
so I had a really odd dream about my
friend and I saw her being abused in
this dream and I've just felt awful
waking up and I just felt like oh my
gosh is this something that I didn't
know had happened to her and I found out
eventually that she had actually been
abused and I felt God saying to me like
there's other people who've been through
this pain that you could help by just
telling your story and I don't want you
to sit on that story because it could
free so many other people and it it it
was really difficult to do it's not
something I would have done voluntarily
but it did help so many people until
today I still get so many more emails
and yeah I'm happy that's it's helped
people have you you've dealt with it the
addiction have you dealt with the abuse
it's something I'm still working on I go
to therapy now I have a Christian woman
who's a therapist who helps me she's
great and yeah it's a it's a slow
learning curve it's something that
happens to me when I was five and I
didn't even realize it was a problem to
us 20 sorry there's like 15 years of
emotional baggage that I still like have
to unpack but I'm really getting there
and I'm I think I'm slowly getting
healthier when it comes to that so it's
a given that the pornography had a
damaging effect on you or the or the
addiction to pornography had a damaging
effect on you how do you feel about
pornography know that as a Christian I'm
not for pornography it I think I think
when it comes to pornography I think
having nuance is really important I
think I think the idea of just being
like oh ban pornography I think is is a
lazy way of dealing with it I think
having conversations especially with
young children about pornography about
body image about consent is so important
because when it comes to porn there's
not much consent involved in the
storylines and I think the NSPCC spoke
about how that's damaging men's young
boys and how they see consent when it
comes to women and it's damaging how
they see consent
in general so I think that's an
important place to start but what's your
view I suppose I suppose I'll narrow it
what is your view of women who say that
they're just merely exerting their
agency when they work in porn I think
that's completely up to them
I respect women's right to do what they
want with themselves I don't think that
nothing should be forced on anyone I'm
just someone who just doesn't believe in
it but that I don't allow that to affect
how I treat anyone who's I have friends
who who are interested in that and who
are more sexually sexually liberated
than I am but I think respecting their
choices to do that is incredibly
important if you had to sum up someone
who hadn't watched any of your videos
who wasn't wasn't following you on
social media if you had to sum up your
you'll approach I guess just candid and
honest my channel since Celia isn't
literally called sincere because I just
tried to be as honest and frank as I can
be yes it is online yes but I've gotten
used to and I look more at the positives
than the negatives what sir thank you so
much for joining us on divided that no
problem